we now turn to an uplifting story on how
acts of kindness can spread and make a
real difference in the world tonight you
can watch a CBS News special called the
gift kindness goes viral with Steve
Hartman in it Steve shares heartwarming
stories of ordinary people changing
lives with simple acts of humanity in
this preview we meet a hairdresser who
gives free haircuts to those in need and
catch up with a bus driver who creates a
community for his students and Steve has
a very special reunion with a young man
he mentored take a look
when I opened up my salon here I always
want red chairs that was something I was
not going to compromise on and I
remember just looking at the chairs and
being like you know this is kind of a
waste like what if I like stuck this in
my car and just went and offered
haircuts like growing up downtown I saw
a lot of people who were struggling and
experiencing homelessness
this was something I had to see for
myself
[Music]
what does it mean that somebody cares
enough to lay their hands on you
you do not because that's the thing I
crave more than anything
this is
the closeness of just human contact
we're gonna care about each other and
we're gonna love everybody right come on
to show his love and understanding hey
Gee Kurt escaped presence throughout the
year I mean you say you like baseball
each one personally selected with that
child in mind my mom got divorced when I
was only four I'll see you tomorrow he's
the father that I always wanted
after we first told this story Curtis
got a promotion to relationship expert
for the district it's gonna be all right
we're gonna work with your mom we don't
everything's gonna be okay okay
Curtis Jenkins message of kindness has
gone viral I know I'm planning to see
for the future be good now kindness love
respect simple simple simple
viral kindness isn't just a current
Trend many of our most famous Charities
were founded on simple acts of kindness
for example Big Brothers Big Sisters
which is now in all 50 states
[Music]
I was a big brother myself several times
in several places including once in
Minnesota
a little nervous I recently went back to
see my little brother been a long time
Robert Dunleavy was 10 when I met him he
was living with his mom and three
sisters no Father Figure Steve plated of
the role of another family member well
you turned out just fine despite your
mother's worries you know you helped
with that Steve you helped a lot with
that never would have thought I'd be who
I am today
um okay don't do that to me
Steve Hartman joins us now you know
Steve it's about time you have to cry
every time one of your stories
my husband's like are you gonna be okay
it's just that hug at the end of that
piece was so beautiful did you know that
you were going to have that impact on
your little brother no I did not I mean
we'd stayed in touch a little bit but he
was very forthcoming with the impact
that the Big Brothers program had on his
life and it was it was good to see and
yes I did cry but I'm not going to show
too much of it and you're you're very
big on paying it forward why is that so
important to you well this is what kind
of restores my faith in humanity of
course when people have a active
kindness done under them and they pass
it along and that's really the premise
of the whole show I started wondering if
if covid can go viral why what's
stopping kindness from going viral and
so that's what we explore dances there's
challenges all these things go viral
nowadays right so why can't kindness
take over the world and we have a
formula that will make it happen well
Steve one of the things that we were
talking a little bit about this in the
Green Room I'd sort of take my cues from
you when I do what to watch because I do
believe that there is a space for
stories that unite and inspire all of us
and you are the master at doing that but
we often the media sometimes gets
painted with this brush that we don't do
that that we actually divide people why
do you feel it's so important and I
really hope this becomes a regular
series at CBS but why do you think that
there's a yearning for programming that
inspires and unites
because we're so divided and people
don't like it and they really do want to
be brought together now there's a this
is kind of a double-edged sword because
people say they want more stories that
unite us but they don't always vote that
way with a remote control we need them
to do that tonight to send a message to
CBS and to other networks that this is
the kind of program we want to see more
of my favorite CBS Morning segment is
kindness 101. It's so good like
everything has to stop when it's on
um and your kids are just
perfect I mean we like you don't you
know you're okay Steve and you don't
live with them so I'm not going every
day going come on you're perfect I guess
you're knocking on their dressing room
door five minutes it's almost Showtime
but I have so many questions so behind
the scenes like how many takes did that
take because they seem like Naturals is
that you're also your real addict addict
it's not an addict it's just it's my
office oh what's your office it's my
office yeah and there are we shoot for
maybe half hour and show the very best
just you know minute yeah so there's a
lot of banter that I would never include
I don't want anybody to ever see now
Steve you mentioned the formula you said
we have a formula
um how do you communicate that formula
to all of the viewers at home well
because again I I wanted to I wanted to
make the point that kindness can go
viral and so we went to MIT and got a
professor at MIT to come up with a how
do we get kindness to go viral what will
it take yes we don't share it people
have to watch tonight they're special
not that hard
it really is this is really doable oh
Steve thank you so much for being here
the kindness his special the gift
kindness goes viral with Steve Hartman
premieres tonight at 10 right here on
CBS and on your streaming device and
streaming service Paramount Plus